[Music]
[Music]
hello happy Thursday everybody I'm Eric
that's Cali how are you doing today Cali
good pretty good all right we are here
because we get to play Skyrim a little
bit early on the switch the game that
you reviewed I think it went up last
night this morning this morning you gave
it an 8 out of 10
quoting I'm gonna quote you Skyrim is
one of the best switch ports currently
available I really think so ok I don't
know Peter Brown reviewed doom on switch
the report and that port was will shaky
yeah not that I expected Skyrim to have
a rough port cuz this game is six years
old but I was really pleasantly
surprised the only bugs that are there
are the ones that have always been there
okay yeah alright let's write into it
you are getting yeah you're getting
chased by some thugs I learned that the
hard way as I was setting this up oh oh
the horse is fighting me now okay so
classically Skyy that's fine that's part
of the shadow horse that's fine I mean
you gotta appreciate a little bit of
that it's kind of that uh that's the
classic alright this time we're not
gonna bring the horse this time I'm not
gonna fight the horse I have so okay I
should clarify I have the Hylian stuff
Eclipse yes amiibos whoa geez there's a
Master Sword I have nothing good I
unequipped the shield so I can use my
magic that's fine you know they are
hired thugs after all but yeah we so you
got those through the amiibos I seen one
article today that we're trying to
verify [ __ ] true or not but there was
an article saying that you don't
actually pose but and they're in the
game we're trying to get but there's
that to verify that though so don't
quote me on that one but if that is the
case that's pretty clear
yeah so it wasn't like breath of the
wild where he was kind of like for luck
of the chance because I remember that
was kind of a pain and it was funny
because during breath of the wild
everyone would make a circle around the
office to be like hey yo and like you
just see a memo finally happening and
that's fine sometimes you got to and I
remember I wanted to be this like
elitist that was like no I will not
you guys are a bunch of cheaters and I
don't appreciate it but ultimately you
know - what did it really net them that
much oh yeah thank you guys all for
tuning in on Twitch YouTube and GameSpot
I'm here with Callie as mentioned and if
you guys have questions for her she did
review the Skyrim on switch port and so
it's looking pretty good I mean like I
haven't seen any like weird like frame
drops or anything like that
yeah the frame it's super solid like I
said the only bugs are the ones that
I've always been in scared so it's okay
we're in right and I guess the other
thing too is a is it okay one is there
motion controls in the game there are so
it's all optional you can turn it off
but the one I do like is the addition of
aiming for the bow and arrow which is
something I used a lot in breath of the
wild okay um and it just is it to
fine-tune my aim so I'm gonna react whip
my magic because that sounds good like
it there we go
yes and there's also like you can wag
the joy cons to to sync between your
sword or like whatever your melee weapon
is okay cool because I know that in Doom
the only thing with the motion control
is that I know of and that uh Peter had
told me was like you do this to like on
the
the joy Khan just to do cool or you kill
and I did it for a while I was like oh
this kind of novel and then I was like
oh this is kind of getting old
so at least there's more functionality
that way how did you how did you look
like the handheld experience was that is
that pretty solid as well I was
pleasantly surprised that it played just
as well handheld as it did docked with a
pro controller so I mean like I do think
the one thing is the text is a little
small in places okay
which for me I'm just nearsighted so
that's probably there's like a me
problem but it like I didn't notice any
hiccups and I like I think they did a
great job of reporting this yeah and
just so people know it is a $60 port or
fifty nine and ninety nine which is you
know we can debate that and then at a
time but that is the price of the game
looks surprisingly like good though it
does it does look really good
obviously like I think this is I'm
almost positive this is like the like
Xbox 360 ps3 version not the definitive
edition that came out last year okay
but like it's still I mean it's oh it
looks old in a lot of places and I do
think there's things that have aged
poorly about Skyrim like I really don't
like the melee combat I like magic and
archery a lot better stuff like that but
oh no I have a lot of love for this game
when it came out I put I think 60 hours
into it like the first week I had it so
that's pretty good yeah it was probably
not a good idea cuz I was still in
school
it's fine you wouldn't be shocked how
many people come into the cream cat and
they're like I'm in my class watching
this and I'm like I don't know if you
should be doing don't tell your teacher
our names if they find out Trey Tracy
dog asking what's the battery life in
handhelds that's one thing that I am a
little nervous about it didn't like
drain especially fast but a handheld
battery can be a little shaky depending
on how intensely like how much you've
been playing and for like how long and
this is a pretty hefty gave I had to
delete a lot of space because I have a
really small memory card in my switch
okay SD card and I had to delete like
three games to make room for Skyrim so
it is a hefty game gotcha but the
battery life like it didn't they didn't
like kill my switch in like an hour or
anything it just so you know and I know
now Scott Ward saying digital foundry
actually has confirmed that it is the
enhanced version it is it's good to know
if we want more details we can check
that video time since I played
originally played on PC yeah so it's
like I obviously like I kind of know
we're at the beginning of the game right
now I didn't have to play too much for
the review yes we're at the beginning
but yeah I have about you I'm pretty
much gone around done everything I've
gone in on that did quest yeah and but
to the point of like it being the
enhanced version is like I am so bad at
identify yeah so Nathan Shepherd uh
bringing up a good point kind of just
harkening what you said which is that
combat has always kind of been lacking
and that's why he just sticks to Beau
and sneak attack those suckers from
behind ambush a mile away which funny
enough is kind of like how you played it
at least when I look at your review
you kind of said you're sneaking around
with your bow and arrow I pretty much
always do sneaky Archer in this game and
I forget how this mountain it's been
forever uh I'm just gonna keep walking
yeah I mostly play sneaky Archer I'm a
big Thieves Guild fan so I'm excited
when I get further into the game to and
I'm just gonna what what someone help so
yeah I think it's and like I said I do
think the motion controls if you're some
if you're used to that like I played a
lot of splatoon too and a lot of I used
motion controls in breath of the wilder
he said and I think that helps with the
aiming sometimes it can be a little
tricky to aim especially if you're like
a low-level Archer
so that actually helped me a lot all
right I'm just this is this is fine yeah
this is what you were doing this yeah
I've seen horses go sideways I who among
us is not a horse go sideways someone
asked like do more this force which
that's hard for me to answer for you I
think it depends on like which came you
want to play I guess doom for me when I
played it wasn't super hot for me with
the with the joy cons the aiming there
wasn't as precise as I wanted it to be
and there were some technical glitches
like sometimes the frames depending on
the area you were in would drop into
like the single digits and that was kind
of like and now that didn't happen very
often and I only played it for like that
little bit on the stream where I could
see that kind of being annoying over
time if it happened a lot but yeah and
then I think the whole allure with
Skyrim just being on switches the fact
that there's portability you can bring
it wherever you want yeah and that's the
thing for me is like I've played so much
of this game that I don't necessarily
need to sit and play it for like hours
on end but I feel like I'm going to end
up doing that and I like the option of
just like taking it with me playing it
on my commute for like maybe an hour
while I
I'm on my way to work and you know it's
not in this case because somebody else
was playing so I have no idea what's
going on right now yeah but it's it's
easy to pick up and play when you know
your way around the map which clearly I
do not right now oh you know what what's
up all right let's go to the ruins yeah
the sound direct is free nostalgic yeah
somebody's pointing out that the
textures looked pretty bad there um
again that something that I kind of
overlooked because this game is pretty
old
and keep in mind that you are seeing it
on a stream yeah there's a lot so yeah
there's a lot of things that sometimes
have to clarify in terms of like when we
stream a game obviously what I see and
what Kali sees is not necessarily
indicative of what you're gonna see on
your computer screen or mobile phone if
you see framedrops hopefully it's not I
didn't see it in the game myself but and
I'm not gonna specifically blame
anyone's internet but that's sometimes a
possibility just throwing it out there
not saying that it is for you Chris but
well I'll keep an eye out for framedrops
I haven't seen anything like to like
game breaking at least from like you
walking around are you in combat just
now it didn't seem like something was
like
I don't know God daddy gave you the
choice which bear is best I'm so dead
this is not good
I've contracted Bonebrake fever you
gotta you gotta believe this is horse I
believe yeah Chuck those minor potions
oh are you still alive yes
okay can you outrun a bear though no I'm
definitely okay like I don't have any
he's angry I would like to clarify that
it is very hard to talk oh that's fine
that's that's it that is a streamers
life welcome but yeah I mean I think the
the port abilities I mean probably the
biggest selling points I'd like yeah do
you feel like that's what you want yeah
if you do cool so whenever we talk about
the switch I like to clarify to people
that I am weird and I prefer playing
games hand-held a lot of the time
there's Japan yeah I you know I I just
really love playing I'm really lazy I
like to play like reclining and for me
that is a huge plus I've been playing a
lot of starting Valley on switch which I
originally played on PC so similar to
Skyrim and having that option for me to
replay a game that I really love and
just do it while extremely lazy is is
something that I am all about so yeah
definitely all for that and I'm not
gonna go back to this barricade yeah
watch out for that rock at dough punched
as a bear to the knee the new 2017 meme
yeah yeah that's the other thing is I I
should say that if you're like tired of
Skyrim if you didn't particularly like
Skyrim the first time around obviously
there's not a lot different here so
you're not gonna be like it's like
that's like that's the kind of like I
see a little bit of the argument of that
in chat a little bit to that you know
it's it's hard to kind of justify buying
it this way yeah
you already own it like on PC and I've
played it a bunch you want like we've
just talked about the portability or if
you just really wanted to support but as
de because I don't know there's the same
for me with doom right I was thinking
like after playing it on switch I was
like man I I honestly don't know in what
situation I feel like that I would
really want it on switch I wanted the
portability of it but once I started
playing it that way I was like ooh this
I don't know if this is what I wanted
you know
and so yeah can you spot does not hate
sonic pedro neato
we liked sonic mania we just didn't like
sonic horses and the same reviewer by
the way did both and he loves Sonic so
boy does love sigh you know what can we
do sanic it's weird too because there
was that whole discussion of like oh man
like Jacob built up all this like like
you know goodwill and everyone was like
so hype because the sonic mania and then
kind of like I don't want to get into
that but you know do you know if they
included survival mode difficulty in
this port that was 84 gesture x i I'm
not sure we can we can check I don't
know mmm legendary legendary goes all
the way up to sick
alright that's that's what we know there
you go what I think I finally found a
way up that okay envy UK saying he has
doom on or he or she has dual on the
switch but bought or sorry oh yeah oh
the bear the snow bear this
just the this is just my life now but he
has deal on the PC but he bought it on
switch because he wanted the portability
and ability to play in the bed we can't
escape the Bears you know bears to the
Nina it's fine there's bears everywhere
what can he do sometimes the wild takes
it out on you you know Carl Magnuson
he played Rocky League this morning uh
you know on on the John so to speak
which was amazing I could see that like
that would be the one time that's
something else yeah John Povey uh FPS
for us on our end at least has been
holding up pretty well cheers to you
thanks for tuning in I I'm just gonna
yeah you do you somewhere else yeah you
go wherever you want wherever your the
this world is your oyster yeah bears do
crave attention it's true they live like
a like a life of Solitude until they get
you know their own Cubs or they find you
know bears hey be someone to mate with I
guess yeah well you know Care Bear
stairs is Carl the winner yeah I can't
bear another pun come on guys snap JD
all right that wasn't a Care Bear says
camera that's it that's true well it
depends on how you look at it it did
look like it was trying to give a hug it
just also clawed while hugging which
then led to death but yes I am loving
all these these puns I really hope I
don't encounter another bear yeah that
was a grisly outcome thanks Ben genka
Ben we do need bear repellent duh planet
media music this is this is true we do
we do need bear oh god Ben Janka I can't
bear watching that happen again look at
what you guys did yeah what's up Zee
Milani I think close probably butchered
your name sorry
how you doing he says he or she says
they're super pumped for this game on
switch oh here we go
bring it on bendito yeah just keep
walking in the fire like a dummy get
that sweet sweet loot maybe I should try
archery all right do it
I have a special hunting bow oh yeah
hunting boss sparks so hard it's okay he
is also missing very much all three of
them are missing really the hardest
thing is like going from playing like a
ton of destiny to play oh nice that
works too playing like Wolfenstein to
playing this because I'm seriously
aiming and then shooting yeah that's
probably the hardest part of our job is
like oh the switch everything ooh almost
got an arrow in the knee oh gotta go to
sleep later and his kick kick here thank
you stopping by
right in the knee I tried I really did I
will say their accuracy is quite poor
for these bandits considering there's so
many of them considering there's so many
of them and that guy is afraid of you
won't even come oh Jesus
just kidding Oh get shots get slowed oh
yeah oh you really did go bow and arrow
man that this is like pop G we're like
leading our shots yes Terry I think Oh
Wolfenstein Wolfenstein - the new
Colossus the new Colossus will be coming
out on switch eventually if it's 2018
I'm about that port yeah I as we've seen
the doom I think
maybe like graphically intensive games
just I mean that's that's probably not
fair to say because we've just seen but
yeah but that's what that what that is
also our reference right like we've seen
whom and that's why that is causing us
to then be worried because of what the
do import was and it you know and that
and Wolfenstein is like to me more
intensive than doom nicely done me good
job and you stuck them to the to the the
cabin wait that's so beautiful
boom there is a me Bo support that's how
we got the Zelda outfit stuff I didn't
bring in the amiibos but she can show
you how you would get it if you had
Zelda yeah I could actually walk people
through that sweet I think Brad
shoemaker borrowed all of our oops I'm
meant to go to the right there we go
borrowed all of our amigos okay yeah so
it's nested and magic weirdly enough
under powers so hello it's automatically
unlocked you get it right away I have it
equipped right now because I was trying
to unlock everything which I did do it
so I can show you guys that so I have
obviously the tunic I have the sword and
shield as well and they are in here
because I have the master sword and it
looks really nice I think that the two
tunic is the dirtiest looking thing I
mean that's how close and Skyrim look
and then I have the shield as well and
the sword is actually the best sword I
have and this is the best armor I have
right now except at the beginning of the
game so it was actually I liked it
because it was useful and so you cast it
like to go to power and then when you
tap the amiibo a chest drops down it
Kappa Zelda amiibo and he's all doing
you both doesn't have to be breath of
the wild you get you get a chance at
getting one of those three gold items as
you had mentioned it wasn't super hard
to get all of them unlike breath of the
why you think I tapped like six amiibo
total o2 chance
I think like the official what they're
saying is like it's 20% chance but for
me it didn't take too long so if you if
you're like a big Zelda fan you have a
lot of Zelda amiibo like you should be
able to get the other thing that's cool
though is if you tap any any amiibo like
it doesn't have to be Zelda just any
compatible amiibo and there's a whole
list on Nintendo's website um you get a
regular chest which just has regular
loot in it the nice thing about that is
like at the beginning of the game like
maybe you just want to sell stuff or
sometimes it's arrows arrows can be
pretty scarce if you're an archer and
you use them a ton gold coin rich I
spend most of my time in this game
looting that's great um yeah so the
middle thing like I I liked it because
it was integrated naturally so it was
like oh this fits with the game that I
know and have played a bunch like it's
not super weird that it's nested in
powers like I think that was a smart
place to put it and I think that loot
him like I did gotta get that money
yeah so it's kind of cool I mean it's
obviously it's like it's not the reason
I would buy it on switch for me that's
the portability but it's it's just like
a nice touch yeah key I can't confirm
the size was it the size of Skyrim for
this was it 17 gigs because that's what
inner hype saying he has a pretty
downloaded that sounds about right
actually because I would I tried to
download it initially it was like ooh a
giant and a bear are you kiss on a bear
that's cow I host if you like this is
outrageous I think I needed like another
14 gigs to me okay Justin yeah so I
didn't like see the exact size but that
that sounds what
did ya cool thank you for that
information about it so I don't worry
archery him don't want to use your
arrows get burns I'm gonna cook you oh
my god
boiling crab boiling crab for dinner
yeah yeah roasted crab roasted I like
out of carry weight Oh someone that's
fine no definitely not very light I mean
not very heavy yeah I'm back with my my
dagger all I want to do is go to like
just join the Thieves Guild look up my
main goal in life
it sounds good yeah good good goal yeah
walk through the dark dark of night and
steal as much as I possibly can that was
the was the was there's all this stuff
like did it feel like Opie when you got
it or is it pretty on par no I can show
you actually like the so I have where is
it
maybe I got rid of it I had my hide
armor and the champions tunic it's for
ta I think my armor was like 32 okay so
upgrade it was an upgrade
for the beginning of the game I'm
obviously focusing on light armor
because I want to be a thief so yeah I
was pleasantly surprised that it wasn't
like just a kind of a throwaway like
cosmetic only thing it was like oh this
is actually a better piece of armor than
what I was yeah that was a weird thing
in a breath of the while because I did a
stream last week with Rob for the the
Xenoblade Chronicles and we were like oh
this kind of looks cool like I could
kind of you know rock this and then
we're like oh we can't upgrade it okay
guess that's done
we can we can show off motion controls
in a little bit yeah I have we have joy
groans we can do that in a little bit
some people are curious Oh sneak on oh
no what I was detected I don't even see
who's looking at me no but there's some
meat cooking now you're here they are oh
I don't think you want to mess with that
I really don't yeah I'm super way too
low level to mess with him sneak away
are you both playing no Callie's playing
right now and I'm here to read this is a
chat and you know try to I'll be sending
the questions Callie is away because
she's she's the the reviewer person for
us here at GameSpot first guy on one
switch guys can check out her review
it's on the site the video is on the
site as well it's also on youtube if you
want to check it out there and there's a
I think Joey did a video of oh my hello
animal Skiba animals are the worst thing
that happened to me in this game right
now yeah at least it wasn't a bear I'm
really glad that was not in there yeah I
think oh okay I just thought the chat
Brandon heat ninety two point out mods I
will say that like I think if you're
used to playing with mods
that can be frustrating I think that can
be a weird adjustment because this is
like basically you know like vanilla ish
Skyrim right I think if you're like if
you have quality of life mods like one
of the mods I really miss is the one
that changes your start because I'm very
tired of doing bleak falls Barrow over
and over again
and when I was reviewing it I was like I
can't believe I have to do plate falls
arrow once again because I created more
characters than I'd like actually played
to completion so that's I mean that's a
trade-off for sure like the portability
playing in bed I'm about that life
but the no mods I can see a lot of in
full struggling with that I'm gonna miss
Thomas the Tank Engine I want to get to
Roark said alright we'll get there make
it you don't wish that was a bear bed
and come on get out of here with that
get cooked get wrecked yeah yeah that's
right Skyrim VR is also almost on its
way we played that live stream that
recently Nick was playing that and that
seemed pretty solid oh that's also
tomorrow derp derpity derp
so Skyrim switches tomorrow but so is
Skyrim VR oh yeah yeah so I'm actually
not reviewing that somebody else is
doing that so I don't know skunky
was it definitive edition that I said it
was earlier digital foundry said that
this is the definitive edition I think
hopefully I said that right someone in
chat will correct me if I'm wrong
that's what cats for that's yeah you
know thanks chat I know you got us are
back so most of the time they've tricked
me before Cali maybe you know it's so
like I've been hurt before I was in like
a long queue for like overwatch I was
like what do you guys think should I uh
over where did that cut I really think
it'd be funny if oh oh oh they got fire
too and they're barred oh there's your
roasting that one pretty good yeah suck
it you're vampires so no blood the
vampires being here you should be firm
for anyone that this includes expansions
yep vampire dusts that dust I'm just
gonna ooh those are fancy cute boots I
don't need that huh I'll oh you stripped
her naked I did made - oh man it's okay
that you did what they did to that poor
soul that's true although I should
probably show karma karma cosmic Wow all
right that guy died in an awful position
that's unfortunate man imagine imagine
going out like that
Skyrim JPEG you gotta like walk over and
like I'm so sorry let me I mean flatten
you out there yeah you did you
desecrated his body I thought maybe I
don't know that's what you're trying to
straighten him out
man I like the comment that's just naked
yeah lowing cloth totally you know stark
naked okay we're making our way yeah we
are
- Oryx dead
I think one of my favorites Kyra moments
is the dude at the beginning who says
he's from Rorick stead like when you're
you're still in hell again and he like
really does not want to die so he says
you're not gonna kill me and he starts
running and they immediately shoot him
down it's one of my favorite just it's a
really a work of art to me okay I can
carry to this marker I could probably
level up what should I do
I don't know you tell me I'm gonna do
health this is a family stream DCP 77 we
try to keep it pg-13 I'll do that later
flames 84 gesture we'll get to it we got
a good 30 to 60 minutes more there's
plenty of time for motion controls and
someone told you to go to wood windhelm
debt dock because they bet that the
frame rate will drop maybe way as
possible yeah yeah Skyrim she's in it
she's it that's what you do
oh hello animals it's alright as long as
they're not bears
we don't care Cali
annoying
I love these like dramatic burning love
giant rats love it and guys to do that
pests got to get rid on ones hut
all right ones what you got I want just
seal everything oh man right in front of
his face
Oh what's happening that's not fair we
didn't even load in yet that's it's full
of fevers yeah it killed the previous
owner or it's his pets yeah well now it
makes it easier to steal yeah yeah it's
not stealing because that's how that
works yeah especially in these times
these trying times only three hours and
30 minutes left here in Sweden before
hammered uh 93 you can play for the
thousandth time I'm sweet yeah he's
looking forward to it that's the thing
is like I don't remember ever coming to
this building like I play this game so
much and it's like never never been
there but all right optics sanity rip
owner that's that is true that is what
happened a hentai boy is gonna get doom
and rocket League to get 10 hours for
d-max in New York are we at that point
oh I guess so I don't know I thought it
was 12:00 a.m. Eastern but you never
know I'm terrible at the release dates I
didn't even know Skyrim VR was tomorrow
until I looked up the date so you know
it's the time especially like this is my
second review this week there's been
like yeah I'm kind of like what day is
it the other one you did was a Pokemon
ultra Sun and ultra moon yes ooh yeah
breath of a wild dlc pack - that's
December Oh God you'll you'll get there
I'll make it Skyrim always let it happen
yes Skyrim wool you'll find a way aha Oh
who's there shaman a shaman
some people say there's a lot
there's three oh hi how do you do please
don't kill me Wow
you fired back are you now declaring
mercy listen I'm already a thief like a
shield this next life
oh yeah she did now she's back in the
she doesn't want you she's not afraid
okay yeah you got to drink some potions
it's time to do my magic huh - yeah do
it
expend everything for the stream get
away
destruction increase
oh she got a lot of life ya know I'm
leaving that seems fair
ya know she I don't want to fight her
right now yeah I kill I kind of want to
dilute this shaming the shaman shaming I
don't know what do you guys say shaming
shaman potato potato
a lot of people want all these like
Triple A or like you know like Triple A
games that came out like fallout 4 Final
Fantasy 15 GTA 5 I just don't know how
they would go
I know Matt a Spinelli is currently
working on la noir which if I recall
right and you can you can maybe help my
memory I think he said docked was fine
handheld there's some moments when
there's like a lot of stuff on the
screen that he kind of like I think like
his this is my impression of Madison l
he's like I'm running kind of slow
thanks Nathan Shepard he said that hag
hag Raven will wreck you we got to run
yeah we definitely dipped out of there
yeah sometimes you got to pick your
battles what's that oh do you have to
put that whatever you just picked up I
[Music]
did you pick up the thing that was on
that body I don't remember it no that's
probably not gonna work right I mean
let's try it would that be too
convenient or the way it should be
haha I don't want to carry that that's
fine got to get rid of it don't want to
be overburdened well
it's interesting going around Skyrim
with absolutely no direction whatsoever
maybe I should do that there's like the
quest the Red Guard gives you and um
white run that's like oh I'm we're
missing a friend and what ya not ominous
at all just just a skull making its way
downtown I'm gonna stop there yeah we
all know what comes after that yeah I I
did that the other day and I regretted
everything yeah there's been some good
ones as beanie missed oeis said for
switch games stardew valley you probably
played the crap geez I think I don't
know steam world dick to Super Mario
obviously yeah it's been a pretty solid
year for the switch I have to say first
party and some good third party stuff so
I know stardew valley was a big one for
you I'm sure Mary's probably picked that
up to now yeah and the multiplayer
update which I detailed yesterday I'll
let you marry other people and I
promised Mary that we would be married
wow that's hot Australia just passed
that law right I'm up on the times right
yeah and like they there's like a patch
I think that that's another thing about
the stardew valley port is a little
janky in some places I tolerated it
because I loved that game but I will say
that it is a little like it oh there's
some times huh there's uh there's some
load time stuff but the paper going to
fix that okay that's encouraging
how are the load times for this game oh
really really easy probably more on par
with another I'm pretty sure you so
boletos cobalt teals asking if you can
use a pro controller to aim the bow like
this joy Khan's I don't think
or you can yeah so I just missed it I'm
sorry oh you can oh sweet okay I lied
I'm terrible
turn it off I usually kind of combine it
the way you would with maybe like it's
platoon where you would use the sticks
and okay but use it to fine-tune your
aim is cool yeah I didn't really do that
at the Bandit area that's fine you could
do it now haha
well next area someone brought up a good
point that Black Friday is coming up so
you know there's a bunch of Black Friday
deals kind of up and out already if you
check out GameSpot we have a bunch of
I'm sure there's a bunch of good deals
potentially for even the switch so yeah
tell us a fun game spot for Black Friday
resources and the like we gotta find
something to bow and arrow I know I want
to find something to shoot that's not a
bear yeah I feel like this is this is
promising yeah I mean even if it's a
moose whatever it's go hunting yeah
hunting we will go all right well we got
here
ah alright let's see how this goes
hi sir okay so this is I'm actually
getting this like under the table and
it's staying nice okay I mean I really
like for like not shooters like not
first-person shooter yes in the
traditional sense
I do but it is going better for sure I
know not that I'm doubting your aim from
earlier but you were you hit almost all
your shots on the other two gentlemen
and I think you hit them there too I
feel like you have an arrow in the eye
so there yeah right oh yeah totally
there it was it was totally in the eye
I swear yeah so are you linked no we
just happen to have some link fit and
there's only three it's not like there's
a ton of yeah what are you look alive oh
he's got no chance if you can that is a
girl that bandit is so screwed needs
more bears as been genka nope we're good
no I'm good with we saw the results of
the the bear fighting we fought two
different kinds of bears they're
sleeping she's just taken a nap she's
good all good and you still nailed the
shot who needs depth perception Oh could
you have killed someone with that oh I
wish I kill I feel like they could have
dropped it on me but I killed them from
up here sneaky trap yeah I thought that
person fell down there awful underscore
switch have you seen the new skyrim VR
that is coming out tomorrow yes we
checked it out I wanna say
Oh two weeks ago give or take
Nick margarita excuse me was playing
that you seemed to enjoy the firing the
bow and arrow
and also using the magic oh no the music
oh you're good they're just they're just
some bandits some casual bandits pretty
lows here you taught them how magic is
really interesting when the music
started up I was like instant yeah like
God she has nothing tera hunter really
happy for you Nintendo peeps though we
sucked the we're the Wii U I didn't even
own a Wii U the only thing I played on
Wii was uh the sports
I owned a we owned a Wii U and I this is
I like to switch I'll say that
a good year to year for Nintendo oh this
guy is too cheap you got it careful who
will die you were him we're screwed
we're hanging on by leg of goat I wasn't
a lot meeting all of it okay
yeah vegetable I didn't mean to that's
fine oh you burned him anyways oh no he
didn't I know he did his but what is he
oh he's got a lot of gold and he's got a
key to the robbers grave where we could
leave or Cove Jesus they all look the
lettering looks the same
we do have gameplay of the VR experience
if you guys are curious yes er so you
can check that out
okay that comes out tomorrow there's
another key here is it just it's the
same thing all right well it's right
down there is the probably this yeah
it's probably this we're gonna go take
their treasures hopefully there's
nothing down here knowing our luck
there's no empty chests alright cool
empty ooh coin purse though glad I
checked that reed bandit leaders Journal
all right idiots Brodie Rand heard we're
at each other's throats again today Oh
bro dear oh they had a good haul that
means there's stuff in here right mmm I
want the cheese nothing I know I'm
trying to get the cheese I think I tried
to take as much cheese as I possibly can
Oh some bread a dagger a dagger might as
well there we go got the cheese my ocean
and I'm stuck there are you fine
and let's see what we got on cabbage I
do want this coin versa yeah
get rich or die trying' logic would
dictate that well is there stuff farther
you can swim right yeah I can swim
journal this way to treasure to Skyrim
burn the fish oh hello
we are outside now alright sure
yep nailed it yes you know blade - does
come out December 1st I think Peters
gonna be on the case I wouldn't be
shocked if that's like an 80 hour game
oh yeah as you know blade is 100% gonna
be very long Phil Elliott Eleanor is out
it came out Tuesday so if you're looking
to play le noir that is out are you
hopefully I don't know you know how far
I'm at is along I don't say but I hope
in my end of the week is my hope or
guess because we got that day of we
didn't get that yeah we didn't get that
early which is sucks for the reviewer
that's pain tough it is tough
yeah I actually never played Eleanor I
mean I played it a little bit I never
finished it so I'm how do you guys keep
showing up they're bandits
we don't have a lot going in life for
you Callie you become a bandit and then
you find a family of bandits and then
you're not alone anymore in the world
that's kind of lovely yeah I know except
he's dead now yeah bye see ya join the
wrong group of bandits like hello coming
in are you sleeping
no I think I killed them all I think I
woke them all up and then I killed them
okay so you know yeah that's fine so
that's one does only plunder except we
don't want that yes I don't want any of
this oh yeah they are definitely already
been here you are correct I didn't I
went right into the cove and I didn't
check this room there we go steel helmet
and helmet but everything else is nice I
love it there's just like rich shower
we're breaking it in I want to get out
of here to be frank okay like I said the
world wherever you want except for when
there's bears then we run away really
fresh I run away goodbye the Bears
so what's your experience in Skyrim I
played very little
I'm not into I don't know I just never
got into it yeah I play like the same
game type if it doesn't have a lot of
loot and a lot of killing and a lot of
having to grind I guess I'm not that
into it I guess it depends hello she's
mad at me because I have my flames out
don't worry yeah I'm not gonna hurt you
yeah it does shoot I miss the person
thing I think pin 76 sex it does have
all the expansions in it yes that is
what we have gathered all right all
right yeah we had I want to do a thing
we're gonna do a round sounds good where
the dead man's respite really really
hoping that it's not um - hey at the
worst we're gonna get some I don't know
we'll find out we'll get to plunder is
my hope but yeah thank you guys all for
tuning in on YouTube twitch games bye we
are playing Skyrim on the switch it
comes out tomorrow or tonight ish
depending on where you're at there it
seems like a mixed bag and chat some
people are like I'm totally getting this
and some people are like I'm just gonna
play it on PC which is I think
okay I was like yeah it's gonna do it
always like what have you chose poorly
oh it's just a dress line there's one
behind it's just three fine the old walk
back and fire the old walk
tried-and-true they can't do anything
there you have no range yeah they didn't
really plan their their attack very well
so well in reality what really should
have happened is that door that you walk
through that closes Sam couldn't do that
but you know what do I know about traps
you know ambushes oh and amulets they
always have gold on them yeah you know
at some point in their life they just
kind of like with that yeah there were a
person that needed to buy stuff Dragon
Claw mmm-hmm that's over here burial
urns nice ten gold like normally I would
spend much yeah you are a lucky ducky
yeah I should have known that was coming
sometimes super luck favours of the bold
yeah yeah there's an there's one of
those skulls that a lot of schools
around look for traps around the floor
keep an eye on the floor that's what I
do every day when I'm walking you never
know if you're gonna step in dog feces
that's the experience already or like
you know step in a crack and just like
roll your ankle oh oh spiders they're
tiny I hate spiders and fire is the way
to deal with spices
fire is the but are you dead just watch
the movie arachnophobia which I will not
do again
good yeah we're good oh he doesn't he
doesn't watch bad messing with that he's
not messing with that what I do
Oh someone shooting a pony right yeah
that's fine
I feel like I should have been following
the ghost man yeah that's fine sometimes
when in the cave you explored oh log
trap dude that's a mom I don't know
that's some predator ish right there
yeah come on I'm here I'm sorry I'm kind
of like insulted that I live I love that
movie he sets the trap and it's like
Arnold's like come on man I got this
huge log trap for your ass all right oh
yeah you knew he was gonna wake up his
Restless
oh no oh he's a strong one - oh well
played Kali well played just say no
you're yeah I'm gonna heal death's door
but that was well played I did not even
consider that that's something you would
do in like a Dark Souls game that oh
that's actually well not the perfect
segue but it it it is a segue for me in
the sense that like you know we're gonna
do extra life this weekend starting
tomorrow at 12 p.m. Pacific we'll be
streaming 72 hours across all three of
our territories the US UK and Australia
the reason why I brought up Dark Souls
is because we kind of have this huge
YouTube community post asking some of
the you know subscribers commenters some
of the games they wanted to see in Dark
Souls was one of them so that was my
segue so you guys should tune in
tomorrow and throughout this weekend
we'll be playing games for the kids
maybe doing some stupid stuff for the
kids and donation - yeah that's okay you
you your instincts kicked in there yeah
we will be streaming for the kids very
excited about it it's gonna be a lot of
fun you're gonna be lost silliness a lot
of exhaustion where that's weird the
lever is oh there it is that's see
that's a well that's an elaborate trap
anything would you like a steel hammer
no okay this is where I was the spiders
right here Oh pick some locks so you can
also lock pick with motion controls but
because I'm at a very low level I
haven't like wanted a mess with it too
much
that's all right up still we have 11
more tries it's fine it will be fine
Oh got this boom our time was a charm uh
50 coins Oh lock-picking increased how
much oh yeah which is a lockpick like a
coin okay so okay so we didn't lose
money in that now that little
transaction there we just came from
there right yeah yeah yeah surprised
dead guy yeah this is where we can't
you're right you're right but then also
that's weird we went through the spider
the spider oh yeah
[Music]
okay we came from you from there the
spiders are over here I can't be the end
of it right no that can't be all of the
things to do right I look for some more
chains I know I'm looking but also look
down I know I'm like oh they're
everywhere we definitely came from here
yes yeah I came down the stairs oh maybe
that other door is open no that left
side that you couldn't go through
earlier up all the way up top
I don't know I'm did we open that middle
path but I also walked over that trap no
problem that was I think that wasn't a
trap yet I can't tell it just looks like
the spikes would come out of that thing
oh okay good you're back either way if
the other sides are open worst case is
we just get out of here yeah I think
that's a normal door also over here let
us in uh huh we could have gone in here
all along was there anything in here Oh
like those I guess what really I guess
that's it wait sometimes it'll say on
the map he completed the thing we're
doing back down we're doing it I'm
getting this gold though I didn't even
see that good eyes yeah okay you know
what we couldn't have been done because
I could I took that Dragon Claw at the
beginning and you got to do something
with it later clearly got to do
something with it okay so go down here
here yep I opened this
[Music]
and yeah I guess we continue to go this
way yeah really want to be thorough here
kill the spiders kill the spiders yeah
we got stuck and then that's when it all
went to hell let's check the map again
yeah the map usually okay okay so this
is the way we want to go we want to go
through this door so we got to do is
figure out how to open that door okay to
the right there behind you yeah okay
that's good okay so we were in here okay
where's the map say oh we didn't come
down this way no or did we oh trap yeah
yeah we totally didn't come totally come
here no I smell danger yep yeah nice my
Dark Soul Spidy Spidy instinct came you
see a lot of webbing there tends to be
some bad [ __ ] that's gonna happen that's
very true
that's always the fun the fun
playthrough of like a Dark Souls type
game is the first time you play it
you're always paranoid like creeping
just walking hella slow because you know
something behind he's gonna fall or come
we are purposely not picking everything
up because Kali would then be
overburdened so for all of you that are
telling me to tell her or saying like
we're missing loot we're not worried
about selling or anything right now I'm
also like I'm thinking that's probably
going to be more boring to watch
normally I would I would go through be
very thorough
I would go through every single thing
your follower tires of waiting in leaves
I don't even know who my follower is I
think it was what's-his-face
feigned all I used him for his archery
skills we had the
what is the map say well sir I can get
down here I don't really want to
ah oh well there's your answer
good luck us alright alright really wish
I was an Argonian right now
is this all no it can't be there there
ha all right
sort of success oh there's a ghost
and there's skeevers damn schemers Oh Oh
big one is coming says Nathan Shepard
prepare for super sized arachnid Oh No
hopefully the fire burns it there's
another dragger
go a narrow one
of the restless longer
oh it's getting hairy use everything for
the shreem Kelly we don't we're not
worried about ya I'm not worried about
saving anything I'm really not married
to this character okay now you just got
the Restless draugar who's now decided
that heat oh boy I was gonna say he was
a dum-dum first stuff not using his
magic anymore but
yeah if I could okay you're still alive
I thought it did the song I thought it
did the slo-mo thing where we were like
dead dead but we're so good all right
cool it's all good guys so shooting you
I think oh you're right yeah just here
the arrows oh good night it's fine it's
fine
someone's at save that's an excellent
idea I'm gonna save with no potions
that's fine you know it's it's all gonna
be fine
worst case is the giant spider eats us
what what double-checking everything I
just I want to make sure I get
everything yeah you do you all right
okay okay yeah I was like is that a trap
it appears to be all right
a little little puzzle here good work
hopefully that stops those yep on cue
all right yep it is a door farther down
the cave we go there's dead man okay
yeah he's like coming this way I dare
you up we're taking something else
actually I wanted to do this because I
have a bunch of stuff that I don't want
to use because it's like battle-axes
okay dissing chat enchant some things do
you do you and also this will help me
you want to keep that though yeah yeah I
need it's fine I don't want to war axe
yeah and thank you guys all for tuning
in we are playing Skyrim on the switch
we're currently going through the dead
man
spit following a ghost and hoping for
the best
we're following a ghost man I'm glad we
found this is a whole endeavor
so this door looks scary yeah oh it's
sealed we can't even go through it
potentially I like that it's like open
sealed door as if like that's gonna you
know what okay I anticipate bad things
too Restless one great well my despair
you know all right do it we are in a
all-in mode right now yeah we're doing
it it's fine where is my destruction
yeah that's a good point
benoît Landry says you can do you have
the healing spell like when we're done
in combat that way that's good that's a
good shout thank you whip okay even with
but that's alright because you're oh
nice okay yes suck it all right
you want your gold I also did not do my
skills oh you didn't okay you know
restoration go back okay yeah I'd like
to preserve my magico possible let's do
that why not why not awesome
I think I have another one actually okay
yeah and then let's see what I have dual
casting I don't really just do that a
whole lot I'm just gonna wait okay save
it okay
more gold is usually golden burial urns
crazy might be I am listening to both
chats as much as I can so if you guys
have any tips or questions send them my
way
and I'll do my best to read the chat Bob
Jones was saying save after leveling
that's probably smart I'll do that
there's something stemming that I don't
want that sword if you like a skull of a
circle protection yes watch out that's
is that a trap yes also this dude is a
hundred percent gonna wake up what's up
Dan the new alright
up good yep preemptive strike
yeah that's what happens when we're
ahead of the game piece yet no loot oh
I'm really bad with directions I know
this place this place is confusing and
I'm just backseat gaming which is the
best no pasaran I hear you where are you
there you are just a normal common day
one what's up Dan the newbie
oh he's restless and he's got ice
use the angles oh there's two of them I
don't think I have any healing potions
left I think you picked up No
[Music]
all right well good luck us well I could
equip my okay
we're gonna run wheel I want that in my
right hand okay okay looking good
yep leave us I crapped myself in here
like an idiot I'm so stupid
no just gotta bathe them the other ones
just an out Rhett a normal one that was
good oh this is going well it's going
surprisingly well and I have enough
magic emotions to get away with this so
that sounds good to me
like I said spare nothing I hate you so
much
ah I escaped okay now what okay now I
can burn though my thing okay
I want a shame in running oh no we there
is no this is I told you we're all in
right now this is just this is what
we're doing
oh yes yeah okay but that wasn't normal
all right no problem no problem at all
okay we got problems now we clearly now
have problems it's okay though we'll
burn more potions hey let's just I'm
gonna go I'm gonna quit my Master Sword
okay so going to magic yep
correct the power of oh god there's more
why okay that one's normal that guy's
the normal one so that's fine all my
restoration is good
I hate I hate it's gonna be fine
I think myself that's all right one guy
the Restless one yeah yeah now we give
them the old shimmy oh maybe not okay
stay tuned next time when you find out
what happens or when we keel over and
we're still healing though we're still
healing Callie we're still healing
all right your call do you want to go
back in and get sweet revenge or do you
want to feel like you know we explored a
nice little cave and I mean not nailed
it well did close to nil you did it yeah
so that was a Skyrim on the switch it's
out tomorrow on the 17th if you guys
want to check that out it's $60 and also
check out Callie's review that was up
this morning eight out of ten yeah you
enjoyed it awesome so remember stay
tuned to extra life we're gonna start
tomorrow at 12 p.m. so an hour later
than our normal time but until then
thank guys thank you so much for playing
Kelly yes thank you for joining me a lot
of fun yeah so see you guys tomorrow
hopefully and gals until next time
bon voyage